en lo que es una protesta prácticamente
sin precedentes efectivos de la policía
de la provincia de buenos aires o la
fuerza de seguridad más grande de
argentina por unos 90 miembros se están
manifestando desde este lunes
contracción en varios puntos de la
provincia de buenos aires- ahora frente
a la residencia de olivos donde vive el
presidente del fernández uno de que
estaba manifestando es el capitán marco
ahora le vamos a preguntar por qué esta
protesta bueno esta protesta va un
reclamo salarial que nosotros estamos
pidiendo lo que es unas horas por es el
el polar nuestro también
que también es poco que está bancarizado
y tratando como 120 días en poder
acreditarlo en el cajero para que
nosotros lo podamos cobrar por la obra
social que en algunos casos no nos
atienden no tenemos las prestaciones que
uno necesita cuando está herido
muy pocas las cosas que nos brindan y
todas esas cosas lo que reclamamos la
condición también laboral los
patrulleros no están en condiciones para
poder salir a recorrer
una vez que hemos puesto dinero de
nosotros para poder repararlos los
cursos de entrenamiento son cortos vamos
muy pocas veces podemos llegar a ir un
polígono porque la verdad que no nos
alcanza el dinero para poder pagar una
línea de tiro el uniforme
que también lo compramos nosotros
nosotros compramos los proyectiles el
uniforme lo compramos nosotros no nos
brindan algo para poder darnos
muchas gracias y esta protesta que se da
frente como decía
quinta presidencial de olivos ha sido
criticada por algunos sectores porque
dicen que la policía no debería estar
manifestándose que no tienen las mismas
condiciones que otros trabajadores que
pueden salir a hacer el mismo tipo de
reclamos de hecho no tienen autorizados
sindicalizarse que es uno de sus
reclamos que además se dan en un
contexto complejo que le agrega
dificultad a la gestión del gobierno de
alberto fernández que ya atraviesa las
dificultades propias de la pandemia de
2019 y una difícil situación económica
aquí en argentina